Pergunta que eu recebi, o polesteral
IDL157 seria alto quando se preocupar
com valor, já que ele também tem papel
na nossa saúde como precursor de várias
substâncias no organismo? Ótima
pergunta, pessoal. Sabe quando você
recebe aquele resultado de exame o LDL
por volta de 150? Aí bate aquela dúvida,
será que eu preciso me preocupar ou não?
Olha só, eu vou te contar uma história
que vai mudar completamente sua visão
sobre colesterol. Anos atrás, quando eu
fui fazer minha pós-graduação nos
Estados Unidos em medicina funcional, eu
conheci um professor cardiologista, Dr.
Mark Houston, que mudou a minha
perspectiva. Nem sempre o vilão da
história é quem parece ser. E é
exatamente isso que aconteceu com o
colesterol LDL. Pensa comigo, por
décadas a gente ouviu que a LDL é o
colesterol ruim, não foi? Mas calma aí,
a ciência evoluiu muito nos últimos
anos. O cardiologista Stephen Sinatra,
que faleceu em 2022, mas deixou um
legado imenso na cardiologia funcional,
já dizia que o colesterol foi encontrado
na cena do crime das doenças cardíacas,
mas não necessariamente ao criminoso.
Ele observava pacientes com LDL de 150
tendo infartos graves, enquanto outros
com 280 tinham artérias limpinhas. É bem
curioso, não é? Então vamos entender
melhor esse tal de LDL 157. Primeiro,
precisamos falar que o colesterol não é
essa coisa do mal que pintaram pra
gente. O seu corpo precisa dele para
produzir hormônios, baend de mielina,
sais biliares, vitamina D, ajudar na
função cerebral. Imagina só, sem
colesterol suficiente você pode ter
problemas de memória, maior risco de AVC
hemorrágico e até problemas
imunológicos. É como se fosse o tijolo
da construção do seu corpo, entendeu?
Agora o pulo do gato está aqui. Não é
tanto sobre quanto LDL você tem, mas sim
sobre o tipo de partícula. É como se
você tivesse uma estrada, sabe? Se você
tem muitas bolinhas de tênis flutuando
suavemente no trânsito, beleza, tá
tranquilo. Mas se você tem um monte de
bolinhas de good pequenas e densas e
cocheteando por aí, aí o bicho pega.
Então, as partículas pequenas e densas
do LDL são as verdadeiras vilãs porque
penetram mais facilmente na parede das
artérias e oxidam mais rápido e causando
sim inflamação. E é aqui que a coisa
fica interessante. A medicina funcional
hoje não olha só pro número total do
LDL. A gente precisa fazer exames mais
específicos, como teste de fracionamento
de partículas, que mostra se suas
partículas são grandes e fofas, as
boazinhas ou pequenas e densas as
problemáticas. Tem também a lipoproteína
A, que o Sinatra chamava de partícula
mais inflamatória e perigosa de todas. E
olha que interessante, você pode ter um
LDL de 157 com partículas grandes e
estar mais protegido que alguém com LDL
de 100, mas com partículas pequenas.
Sabe o que mais?
A inflamação é o verdadeiro bandido
dessa história toda. É como se o
colesterol fosse bombeiro tentando
apagar o incêndio da inflamação nas suas
artérias. Quando você tem inflamação
crônica, seja por causa do açúcar em
excesso, seja pelo estresse, intestino
hiperpermeável e toxinas, aí sim
colesterol pode grudar na parede dos
vasos, mas sem inflamação ele circula de
boa, fazendo o seu trabalho normalmente.
E tem mais uma coisa que muita gente não
fala. A relação triglicérides ou
triglicerides HDL é super importante. Se
você dividir seus triglicerídes pelo HDL
e der mais que dois, isso indica
resistência à insulina e maior risco de
partículas pequenas e densas. é um
marcador baratinho que diz muito sobre
saúde metabólica.
Agora, voltando ao NDL de 157, na
medicina funcional, a gente considera
vários fatores antes de entrar em
pânico. Qual que é o seu HDL e os seus e
os seus triglicerídios? Tem histórico
familiar? Como está a proteína C reativa
que mede a inflamação? E a insulina de
jejum? E a homocisteína? Será que fuma?
Será que tem pressão alta? Tudo isso
conta muito mais do que um número
isolado. E olha que bacana, estudos
recentes mostram que cerca de 50% das
pessoas que tem infarto tem LDL normal.
Isso mesmo, metade. Então, claramente
tem algo além do LDL acontecendo. A
inflamação medida pela proteína ser
reativa, ultra sensível, muitas vezes é
mais preditiva de problemas cardíacos do
que o próprio LDL. Deixa te contar um
segredo que poucos médicos convencionais
falam. Se você tem cidabólica, aquela
combinação de barriguinha, pressão alta,
glicose alterada, triglicerídeos altos,
HDL baixo, aí sim o RDR de 157 pode ser
preocupante, porque nesse contexto as
suas partículas provavelmente são densas
e pequenas.
Mas se você tem uma cinturia fina, faz
exercício regularmente, tem HDL alto,
triglicerídeos baixos e glicose normal,
esse mesmo LDL de 157 pode não ser
problema nenhum. E sabe o que que é mais
legal? Dá para melhorar o perfil das
suas partículas. Naturalmente cortar
açúcar e carboidratos refinados é
fundamental. Eles são os verdadeiros
vilões que causam inflamação e produzem
partículas pequenas e densas. Ao
aumentar gorduras boas, como azeite,
abacate, castanhas, peixes ricos e
ômega-3, isso melhora o tamanho das
partículas. E não tenha medo da gordura
saturada natural. Manteiga, óleo de
coco, carnes de qualidade. O Sinatra
adorava óleo de coco. Dizia que por ser
saturado oxida menos e protege o corpo.
Exercício físico também é poderoso, não
precisa virar maratonista, mas uma
caminhada vigorosa de 30 minutos por dia
já faz diferença. Subir a escada, se
mexer, tudo isso aumenta o HDL e melhora
o perfil das partículas. E gerencial
estresse é fundamental. O cortisol alto
bagunça todo o seu metabolismo lipídico.
Ah, e tem uns suplementos que podem
ajudar muito com enzima Q10, que o
Sinatra chamava de nutriente maravilhoso
para o coração, ômega-3 de qualidade, né
quem tem lipo proteína alta, berberina,
que funciona quase como estatina
natural, mas sempre com orientação
profissional, claro. Agora, quando
realmente se preocupar se você tem
histórico familiar forte de doença
cardíaca precoce, se tem outros fatores
de risco, como é o caso diabetes, doença
renal, se já teve algum evento
cardiovascular, aí sim um RDL de 157
merece atenção especial. Nesses casos,
as diretrizes mais recentes sugerem LDL
abaixo de 70 ou até 50 casos de risco
muito elevado. Mas olha, o mais
importante é entender que a saúde
cardiovascular é muito mais que um
número de colesterol. É sobre
inflamação, resistência à insulina,
qualidade do sono, manejo do estresse,
conexões sociais, propósito de vida. é
um conjunto. Focar só no LDL é como
olhar apenas uma peça do quebra-cabeça.
E deixa eu te falar uma coisa que eu
aprendi nesses anos todos na medicina
funcional. Cada pessoa é única. O que
funciona para um pode não funcionar para
outro. Por isso, a importância de uma
avaliação completa de maneira
individualizada que olhe para você como
um todo, não só para um número do papel.
Então, respondendo definitivamente a sua
pergunta inicial, RDL de 157 é alto a
resposta, como já falei, depende pra
medicina convencional, que considera
normal até 120. Para quem não tem
fatores de risco, sim, está um pouquinho
elevado. Mas para medicina funcional que
olha o seu contexto como um todo, pode
ser perfeitamente aceitável se suas
partículas forem grandes, a sua
inflamação baixa e você não tiver outros
fatores de risco. O importante é
investigar mais a fundo, fazer os exames
adequados, entender o seu perfil
metabólico completo. No final das
contas, o que a gente quer é prevenir
doenças cardiovasculares de verdade, não
apenas baixar números. Isso se faz
olhando o filme como um todo, não apenas
uma foto. O seu RDL é apenas uma peça
dessa história. A verdadeira prevenção
vem de um estilo de vida antiflamatória
com comida de verdade, movimento,
sono reparador, conexões significativas
e propósito. Isso sim é medicina do
futuro, ou melhor, medicina do presente
para quem já acordou para essa
realidade.